was there a phase in there that you're
like you skipped over that you
visited later on in life and you're like
oh this is a little out of order but
yeah no i know exactly what you're
saying um i
you know i went through some phases
actually before
i even ended up on that 70s show um
and you know so i i've had
all all the phases just like you know
just like you're talking about
i may be a little bit out of order
because i
i feel like a cat sometimes where i've
had like nine lives of like i look back
at my life
i have like this period of time before i
started that 70s show
and that was like one life and then once
i got on that 70 show that was like
another life and then that ended which
was such an error you know
in my life 70 show was eight years and
then i you know moved on from that into
like
you kind of like graduate other stuff in
your life
it's just um i've had these like
specific periods of time and now being a
mother this is like a whole new
life of like being a wife and a mother
um
and also juggling your career you know
because i'm a working mom so it's like
it's i've had these like so many lives
happen
nothing i did was like your typical
and sounds like same with you you know
you go to school you graduate you go to
college
you graduate you get a job
and then you're just like in the thing
and we kind of did it
a completely different way um
so yes i definitely had all the phases
and they they
are pretty out of order but when i look
back there's definite what i will say is
i'm so glad
i went through the phases i went through
at the time i went through them
because you know there's certain things
where i'm like okay glad that happened
before i was
you know like you know whatever whatever
it was
like experimenting with whatever or um
you know
i don't know any of the stupid things
that kids do
um with like alcohol or whatever dumb
stuff
that we all do it's like you know
i definitely because i had such a free
upbringing
in so far as like rules um i had a lot
of freedom
um i definitely like did a lot of stuff
as a youngster
that i would be really bummed out if i
knew my kids
you know that is kind of a bummer that
you know you i want to be able to like
talk to them and i i didn't have that
but i had a lot of other great stuff you
know i had
the trust for her to let me go and the
trust to be like
what do we have to do to you know when i
was like learn how to act and she was
supportive of all that like i would
never be where i am without my mom
um my dad passed away when i was young
which is why i keep referring to my mom
and on my dad
is your mom still alive she is she is
she has
um she's had pretty bad
um dementia for a while so
it's kind of nearing the phase of like
there's really nothing more the doctors
can do it's just like
we just have to kind of manage it with
you know
good food and whatever medication we can
but um but you know i'm gonna go see her
on
you know saturday i'm gonna go see her
and bring my kids to see her and
i don't think she will remember my kids
but
but it's fun like we're just trying to
enjoy the time that we have and stay
present
you know but um but it's interesting
because
because my mother will never have
that because she's had it for a while
now
and we'll you know we'll never have that
like end of the scene in the movie where
it's like
the cathartic you know moment of like
why couldn't it have been like this or
like talk to me about this like
why did this happen and you know we'll
never have that and that's another thing
i've really had to kind of kind of turns
with too
like that's okay we're never gonna have
that conversation
um it's not life is not a movie
you know what i mean you're not gonna
have that third act monologue of like
this is what happened you know what i
mean whatever but
it's it's interesting but um but yeah i
mean
to answer your question i went through a
lot of phases just like we all do
just like we all do and uh i'm really
happy to be exactly where i am
right now talking to you thank you what
do you do what do you do to ground
i mean i know you say you love cooking i
mean i know you love cooking and i know
that's something that you've said you do
to relax but is there anything outside
of that that you
that you've developed over time where
you're like these things
really help me to feel like i
re-baseline or reorient or
feel grounded and can then sort of take
on the world again
yeah i mean i'm i'm a really physical
person so i do
really well when i'm active so if i'm
having a really
tough day like struggling with um
because that you know
this last year and a half has been so
hard on all of
everybody no matter where you are in
your life it has been
tac like taxing that's a silly word it's
been like
you had to really deal with yourself you
know what i mean there's no distractions
it's like you're locked down you're you
know
in it and you're really having to look
at yourself and your life
and what this all means and also it's
emphasized in relationships so and
yeah that's why they either failed yes
or they
grew exactly exactly totally
um so for me i really especially this
year i really realized that i need to be
physical i need to be active and i feel
like that
really helps my my head space so
if i'm like having an overwhelming day
or whatever it is or i'm really worried
about my kids or
whatever because i worry about my kids a
lot that's like something i'm always
trying to
quell that's normal i i mean like and
that's like that's the way you're
programmed i just did an interview with
a guy named jordan peterson he's
canadian he
um he's a theolo he's like
he talks about theology and psycho he's
a psychologist as well
he's a really interesting guy but one of
the things that he uh he wrote the 12
rules for life book
but one of the things he said is that
when a woman hits
puberty she all of a sudden becomes
heightened
to to um anxiety
she's much more predisposed to the
anxiety because she's now entering into
fertile years and
part of the role of the mother is to be
on high alert so women have
a much higher chance of having anxiety
because you
are the one that cares for the child you
are the primary i mean i know that
there's a father but
you know you're for a while you are the
only one when you're pregnant
and so a woman a woman once they hit
puberty
and he said it never goes away he said
once they hit puberty they're more
more have more anxiety and then of
course when you become a mother
it's even more because it's your role
that is it's it's like a it's a primal
um baseline sort of feeling so you're
not wrong this is a normal thing
yeah i mean it's i mean i look i
my son is just over a year old now and
um
it was definitely easier with him having
gone through it with
with my daughter but you know when i do
when i talk to my
friends who are mothers and and their
partners as well
um it does get better
and and it's even gotten better for me
already
um it definitely gets better but my kids
are so young and i'm still such a new
mom that
yeah the worry is like overwhelming it's
overwhelming so i do what i can
and again like it like we touched on
earlier i
that wasn't my personality before like i
didn't even know
that that was part of my makeup and i
didn't have kids until i was 36
um that's what i had my daughter but
because i focused on my career and i
wanted and i i felt for me everybody's
different but for me it was important
that i wanted to have kids with my
partner
that was very important to me um
and i wanted to wait you know until
i found my partner and you know thank
goodness
it happened but um but you know
in terms of negotiating that kind of
anxiety which i haven't really
dealt with i've dealt with regular life
anxiety of like work stress and you know
whatever like family stress like we
always have a lot of family drama
um uh you know we're irish catholic and
half
russian jewish and there's like a lot of
a lot of
like you know um it was just
my family is outrageous big and
yeah it's just like it's outrageous um
so there's always like stress around the
family and whatever and blah blah blah
but it's funny it's always funny like
holidays with my family i mean now it's
different you know
now we have kids so we always have to
like be careful of that but
before we were all parents it was just a
comical
uh situation it was like home for the
holidays
all the time like it was just crazy um
even though i haven't seen that movie
for years so i don't know if that
reference still works i'm gonna say you
should probably make a movie about
your family yeah oh my gosh it would be
an amazing movie
um what what was i talking about um and
that's the other thing too after kids
you start like forgetting things
but being physical working out things
like spinning i've like a spin like in
my office and stuff like that that
really helps keep my
my mind kind of centered that really
helps a lot
things like yoga i know that sounds like
a
everyone's like yeah of course yoga but
really whenever i do yoga i always feel
a lot better
and i'm gonna start doing this thing um
i don't know anything about it i just
heard about it called the alexander
technique have you heard of this
it's about like breathing so there's a
lot of stuff that i've really been like
studying recently about like
breath just like breathing like
did you remember did you read the book
breathe yet no
i haven't either i brought it with me
i'm i'm like trying to get away from the
arizona heat right now so i brought some
books and that was one of them
is it all about breath and how that is i
mean your breath is everything if you
think about it
yeah well i think that's actually why
yoga feels so good if that that's what
i've identified recently as i'm like
you know because like pranayama
breathing kundalini breathing
right off breathing all these different
things right they they really can
i mean you can get yourself high with
them like their breathing is incredibly
powerful
and even if you just think if i'm
stressed if you just took one
deep breath you already feel better like
think about yoga
exactly you know what's funny is i was
talking to a friend of mine
and he was talking about smokers and
he's like you know that's why smoking
calms people down because yes of course
it's the chemicals but he's like
you're taking big diaphragm breaths yes
and i was like oh my gosh that's like uh
yeah that makes perfect sense but anyway
so i'm
i'm really learning more about breathing
and you know my husband's done
movies where he's portrayed navy seals
and guys in the military and
they always talk about breath they
always
always talk about breath and remaining
calm and
focused and any kind of um
studying any kind of you know athletes
it's a lot of
it's a lot of breath and remaining calm
and all that so
i i'm really my new thing is i'm
researching about breath
and i really try to find time to have
self-care and be active